فشل في التصدي لهجوم السابع من اكتوبر ثم
فشل في تحقيق اهداف الحرب على حماس خسر
المئات من الجنود والضباط ويتعرض
لانتقادات لاذعه من المستوى السياسي اي
جيش تقاتل به اسرائيل في قطاع غزه لم يكن
يوما عاديا على الجيش الاسرائيلي وقد بدا
بسيطره كتائب القسام على قرابه 600 كيل
متر مربع مما يعرف بغلاف غزه فقد الجيش
السيطره على 2% من الاراضي المكلفه
بحمايتها اخفق على مدى 48 ساعه في استعاده
السيطره على المستوطنات التي اقتحمها
المقاتلون
الفلسطينيون خلال هذه الساعات كان الجيش
الاسرائيلي قد خسر اكثر من 300 جندي وضابط
قتل بالاضافه الى اصابه اكثر من 2000 واسر
القسام اكثر من 130 ضابطا وجنديا خلال
المعركه الاهم ان الجيش في ذلك اليوم خسر
فرقه كامله تتكون من ثلاثه الويه ووحدتي
نخبه هي فرقه غزه تقول كتائب القسام ان
الفرقه سقطت بالكامل يوم الهجوم الكبير في
السابع من اكتوبر وقد استهدفتها بضربات
مباشره تحديدا في الهجوم على قاعده رعيم
العسكريه مركز قياده الفرقه عهد الى هذه
الفرقه السيطره على قطاع غزه منذ عام 67
وحتى الانسحاب عام 2005 بعد ذلك تمركزت
الفرقه خارج حدود القطاع وبقيت مكلفه
بالسيطره على القطاع امنيا وعسكريا
واستخباراتياً كان المستوى السياسي في
اسرائيل قد قرر الهجوم على غزه ليحقق
هدفين انهاء وجود حركه حماس واستعاده
المحتجزين بهذين الهدفين انطلقت العمليه
البريه الاسرائيليه في غزه اواخر شهر
اكتوبر بعد ثلاثه اسابيع من هجوم
حماس خلال مئات يوم من القتال على الارض
خسر الجيش الاسرائيلي اكثر من 510 جنود
قرابه 200 منهم سقطوا منذ بدء هجوم البري
قبل 70 يوما اكثر من ربعهم من الضباط
توزعوا بين قاده سرايا وقاده فصائل وقاده
الويه بمعدل ثلاثه جنود او ضباط يوميا
بالاضافه الى جرح اكثر من 5000 واكثر من
9000 جنديين وضابط يعانون اضطرابات
النفسيه احدهم مات بسكته قلبيه بعد عودته
من غزه من هول ما شاهد فيها وخساره رفاقه
اثناء القتال واخر استيقظ من كابوسه ليطلق
النار على زملائه اثناء نومهم هكذا يبدو
ان الجيش الاسرائيلي ينزف على المستويين
الفردي والجماعي تتاكل قدره الجندي على
القتال ويعجز الجيش مجتمعا عن تحقيق اهداف
الحرب التي يخضها منذ اكثر من ثلاثه اشهر
لا تزال المقاومه الفلسطينيه قادره على
المواجهه من مسافه صفر في اكثر المناطق
تدبيرا بالقصف واطلاق الصواريخ حتى من
الاماكن التي اعلن الجيش انه سيطر عليها
وقضى على قدرات حماس العسكريه في الوقت
نفسه يفشل الجيش في استعاده اي من الرهائن
في غزه يقتل ثلاثه رفعوا الرايات البيضاء
بعد خروجهم من محبسهم ويقتل اخرون اثناء
محاولتهم التقدم لتحريرهم بل ويقتل من
الجنود الذين يخضون التجربه تسقط الروايه
الاسرائيليه العسكريه في مفاصل كثيره من
المعارك ابرزها روايه مستشفى الشفاء التي
رسمها الجيش وتحولت لاحقا الى سخريه على
منصه التواصل
الاجتماعي هكذا يتراكم الفشل الاستخباراتي
والامني والعملياتي والاعلامي على كاهل
الجيش الاسرائيلي رغم اعلاناته المتكرره
عن السيطره على مراكز قياديه لحماس او
تفجير انفاق يصفها بالاستراتيجيه او قتل
قاده ميدانيين في المقاومه لكن الازمه لا
تكمن فقط في غزه ثم مواجهه اخرى يخوضها
الجيش في الجبهه الداخليه لفهم التفاصيل
اكثر يجب فهم طبيعه التركيبه الحاكمه في
اسرائيل
[موسيقى]
يقود الجيش رئيس الاركان هيرتس هاليفي
ومسؤوله في الحكومه ووزير الدفاع يوف جلت
هذان رجلان على خلاف مع اعضاء الحكومه
الاخرين وبالتحديد الوزراء الاكثر تطرفا
وزير الامن القومي اتمار بنفير ووزير
الماليه بيتسلا ايس موتتش على المستوى
الوزاري تسود علاقه من التوتر بين وزير
الدفاع يو اف جلنت من جهه ورئيس الحكومه
نتنياهو ووزير الامن القومي تمر بنفير
ووزير الماليه بتسلئيل سموتريتش من جهه
اخرى فرغم ان جالنت عضو في حزب اللكود
الذي يتزعمه نتنياهو فانه يعارض التعديلات
القضائيه تلك تعديلات يريدها الوزيران
بينغ فير و سموتريتش بينما يعتبرها جلنت
خطرا امنيا على اسرائيل لذلك الموقف الذي
اعلنه جلنت كان نتنياهو قد اقاله بضغط من
بنفير لكنه تراجع عن القرار بعد اسبوعين
وابقاه في الحكومه اما على المستوى
القيادي العسكري الذي يقود المعارك في غزه
فيتعرض رئيس الاركان الى انتقادات واسعه
ولاذع من وزراء في الحكومه ابرزها من
الوزيرين الاكثر تطرفا بينغ فير و
سموتريتش ينتقد الوزراء رئيس الاركان
متهمينه بالفشل في التصدي لهجوم السابع من
اكتوبر والفشل في تحقيق الاهداف العسكريه
التي وضعتها الحكومه الهدف هو تبرئه
المستوى السياسي والحكومه من المسائله ع
ما حدث وتحميل الامر للمستوى العسكري
بالتالي يسعى هؤلاء الوزراء الى تحميل
هاليفي كشخص والجيش كمنظومه المسؤوليه عن
هذا الفشل لذلك اتهم نتنياهو صراحه
المستوى الامني بعدم التحذير مما قد تفعله
حماس لم يتم تحذير رئيس الوزراء تحت اي
ظرف من الظروف وفي اي مرحله من نوايا
الحرب لدى حماس بل على العكس من ذلك قدر
جميع المسؤولين الامنيين بمن فيهم رئيس
جهاز الشباك ان حماس قد ارتدع ولجات الى
الهدوء ساعات فقط بعد موجه غضب انتقادات
مسح نتنياهو التغريده واعتذر عنها لاحقا
واكد دعمه الكامل للمؤسسه الامنيه والجيش
الذي يقاتل في غزه يرد رئيس الاركان على
هذه الاتهامات بتشكيل لجنه امنيه للتحقيق
في اسباب الفشل امام هجوم حماس يضع على
راس هذه اللجنه شاؤول مفاز وهو رئيس
الاركان السابق الذي يبغضه وزراء الحكومه
المتطرفون يعتبر مفاز صاحب خطه الانسحاب
من غزه عام 2005 عندما كان رئيسا للاركان
في حكومه ارييل شارون تعيين مفاز احد
المهندسين الرئيسيين للانفصال غير الشرعي
الشريك الاساسي في التصور الذي اوصلنا الى
هذه النقطه لفريق التحقيق في احداث السابع
من اكتوبر هو امر خطير بمستوى
الخطيئه تقول هيئه البث الاسرائيليه ان
هذه الانتقادات التي يتعرض لها هاليفي من
وزراء تمت بالتنسيق مع مكتب نتنياهو تفيد
وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه ان رئيس الاركان
يتجنب حضور اجتماعات المجلس الوزاري
الامني لتجنب الانتقادات التي قد توجه له
وهو في خضم القتال اذ يجب على رئيس
الاركان ان يجتمع بالمستوى السياسي ثلاث
مرات اسبوعيا مرتين مع مجلس الحرب الذي
يضم نتنياهو ووزير الدفاع ووزير الدفاع
السابق المعارض بن جانس ومره اخرى مع
المجلس الوزاري المصغر للشؤون الامنيه
والسياسيه الكابينت الذي يشمل 15 وزيرا من
بينهم بنفير و سموتريتش وفق التسريبات فان
اخر جلسه شهدت مشاهده كلاميه حاده وصراخه
بين جالنت وجانتس وهالي من جهه وبين جفير
وسموت وميري ريجف من جهه اخرى غادر
مسؤولون امنيون كبار الجلسه قبل نهايتها
واصطف نتنياهو مع اعضاء حكومته مطالبا
هاليفي بالاصغاء الى
الوزراء هكذا يقاتل جيش اسرائيل على الارض
وفي الغرف المغلق يقول مسؤولون في الجيش
انهم يقاتلون في غزه ولبنان والضفه
الغربيه والحكومه تقاتلهم عل هذه العباره
تلخص الظروف الميدانيه والسياسيه التي
يقاتل فيها الجيش الاسرائيلي 100 يوم من
النار لم يحقق فيها الجيش الاسرائيلي ايا
من الاهداف التي وضعت له ووضعها لنفسه ولا
يزال القتال مستمرا حتى الان بكل ما فيه
من خسارات في الميدان وازمات في الجبهه
الداخليه